كل عبارات الدعم التي سمعت في هذه القمه
هل هي كافيه لطمس الخلاف بشان انضمام
اوكرانيا الى النيتو هناك توافق في الاراء
انه من المحتم ان اوكرانيا في مرحله معينه
سوف تنضم الى حلف شمال الاطلسي ما من دوله
في التحالف تعارض انضمام اوكرانيا الى
النيتو توافق الاراء الذي نراه اليوم لم
يكن دائما ما هو الحل عليهم الرئيس
زيلينسكي عبر عن خيبه امله بالنسبه الى
غياب الجدول الزمني للضمامي اوكرانيا
للتحالف ولكن الف شمال الاطلسي اوضح في
صياغه بيانه بشكل دبلوماسي ان مستقبل
اوكرانيا هو مع حلف شمال الاطلسي ملتزمون
بما يسمى سياسه الباب المفتوح للنيتو
اوكرانيا احرز التقدما جيدا في هذا
الاتجاه لكن في الوقت ذاته الاوكرانيين
وغيرهم يعترفون بان امامهم المزيد من
العمل والاستمرار في اصلاح جيشهم والتعميق
الاصلاحات الديمقراطيه فاذا حدثت اوكرانيا
جيشه واذا اجرت اصلاحات ديمقراطيه وانتهت
الحرب ليصبح اوكرانيا طريقها ممهده للنيتو
هذه
الشروط واسعه عريض يمكن ان يتم استفاء هذه
الشروط بشكل سريع
وسهل من قبل اوكرانيا اوكرانيا فيها فساد
وهو امر معروف
والحلفاء والدول الاعضاء في حلف شمال
الاطلسي تود ان ترى تقدما في اوكرانيا على
هذا الصعيد ان هذا من بين الشروط اذا ما
ارادت اوكرانيا الانضمام والرساله التي
خرجت من هذه القمه رساله الاخرى اليوم هي
ان حلف شمال الاطلسي سوف يعزز القدرات
العسكريه الدفاعيه بشكل كبير من اجل حمايه
كل شبر من اراضي الدول التابعه بالنسبه
الى مثال مقدونيا كان هناك
فتره انتظار
للانضمام الى النيتو لتسعه عشره سنه بحسب
الشروط الخاصه بحلف شمال الاطلسي وهو ما
لم يطبق على اوكرانيا هل يمكن باي حال من
الاحوال في اي سيناريو ان تنضم اوكرانيا
الى النيتو وهذا النزاع الحدودي موجود يجب
دراسه الموقف الروسي في هذا السياق في
العام
2008 اجتاحت روسيا واحتلت اجزاء من جورجيا
والحلفاء ارادوا ان يواجهوا هذا الموضوع
وبالتالي هناك تاريخ طويل من المحاولات في
التوسعيه
للاتحاد الروسي بالنسبه الى اوكرانيا سوف
تنضم في نهايه المطاف الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي بالرغم مما قاله السيد زينب